look I'm not gonna lie rebel you got a
lot of work to do and Walker assault
mode that the Imperials just don't have
to and if you want to win it's gonna
take some smart planning a lot of
coordination and maybe some last-ditch
tow cable skills there are three
sections of the map each of which rebels
must hold two uplink stations in order
to stack up as many y-wing bombers as
they can that will then make a gun run
on the 8080 and make it vulnerable to
ground fire don't think about it a good
chunk of the 80 ATS armor must be taken
off at each phase or rebel stand little
chance of winning phase one arm the
uplinks uplink stations are the
payphones of the Star Wars universe that
make very specific collect calls to
wowing bombers it takes a really long
time for those calls to go through so
equip the personal shield card and make
sure to get your hands on the bubble
shield pickup you need to be able to
hold the uplinks long enough to stack up
four to five y-wing bombers per section
of the map that means a lot of standing
there and holding them up links or you
could push forward and keep Imperial
forces away you can't stop the 88 es
however which reign constant heavy fire
and orbital strikes on your head hence
shields don't stop to think about how
the 8080 is calling in the orbital
strikes when the rebel shield generator
is still online
I said don't think all right your calls
went through uber has sent four to five
y-wings to hit the 88 es and make them
vulnerable to ground fire it's now your
job to shoot the walkers with everything
you can which is actually not a lot
because of that it's best if your team
can concentrate fire on just one Walker
at a time use your cards or your buddies
cards ion shot and ion grenade to
maximize damage in the short window you
have if your only option is to shoot
with your primary rifle master the Gears
of War style reload to keep the blaster
bolts coming basically hit the right key
when the cooldown gets to the yellow bar
in the red cooldown meter but that's not
nearly gonna be enough to stop a walker
your team will need to have had some
foresight and stockpile smart Rockets
anti-vehicle turrets and orbital strikes
yep those mariokart coin things you keep
grabbing hold on to them like they're
gold or whatever passes for golden in
the Star Wars universe your team will
also need to use ground turrets and air
assets and while you're doing all this
you'll be getting shot in the face by
stormtroopers a tsts and the Walker
itself basically just shooting the
Walker with your Prime
is never gonna cut it you have to do
significant amounts of damage in each of
the three map sections
rinse and repeat three times and you'll
probably lose until this gets some
rebalancing at least but hey it's a beta
right well all is not entirely lost if
you hit the last phase and the walkers
have a lot of help rebels have one more
trick up their sleeves
the snowspeeders can initiate their tow
cable QuickTime event during the
Walker's damaged phase that can end the
four legged tanks once and for all so if
you get the snowspeeder early steer
clear of the battle until the walkers
become available and then swoop in for
the save and lest the time runs out or
the QTE crashes you into a mountainside
hey good luck rebel we all know you end
up losing on Hoth anyway what are your
thoughts on the Star Wars Battlefront
beta
have you played Walker assault mode what
are your strategies let us know in the
comments below and stay tuned to Games
Bob comm for more coverage of Star Wars
Battlefront
you